the movie begins in a prison cell where
a man named Frank Adrian is spending
time with his wife Frank seems to have a
reputation inside the prison he rooms
with the guy named Jean-Louis Morrell
who was charged with assault and is a
guy who keeps to himself he seems to be
a Hot Topic amongst the cell mates at
night Adrian finds morel's diary and
goes through it due to his innocent
personality Adrian thinks that maybe
morale was innocent after all the door
to their cell opens up at night and
three men Adrian had an encounter with
make their way into the cell they tell
him to move out and they beat Morel up
thinking of his innocence Adrian makes
his way to the cell and a fight breaks
out the prison guards make their way
inside and break the fight the scene
shifts to a visitation time Adrian
informs his wife Anna about last night's
events he also tells her about the added
sentence worried Anna asks about the
whereabouts of the money Adrian had
stolen she wanted to use it to pay for
his expenses not trusting her he refuses
to tell her at the same time morel's
wife Christine informs him about the the
charges of assault being dropped while
exiting the prison Anna has an encounter
with Christine who has a polite
conversation with her the scene changes
to inside the prison while the prisoners
enjoy a classical music show novik
Adrian's partner shoves a screwdriver
inside his ear demanding the position of
the stolen money giving him a fake
address Adrian falls to the ground as he
gains his Consciousness he finds Morel
sitting next to him Morel informs him
about the situation novik got a weak
solitary but Adrian had been out for
four days that gave Adrian three days to
get out of prison Morrell questions
Frank about the money telling him that
the entire prison knew and he even
offered to help Frank questioning him on
how he could help Morel tells him that
he was being released morale gives Frank
his phone number as a thank you about to
leave Frank asks Morel to call Anna and
warn her about novik he also tells him
that she should go see his father and
that he will help him out it is revealed
that the stolen cash was inside his
father's grave in the next scene Morel
is seen leaving a cell but is collecting
hair out of a comb and stores it into an
empty medicine box he leaves prison and
meets up with his wife a few days later
Frank is visited by a retired officer
named Manuel carrega who questions him
about Morel he confronts Adrian about
the dangers of the man the scene shifts
to Marella Anna's house where he keeps
eyeing Frank's daughter Emily Morel is
seen behind Anna when the scene changes
to Frank trying to call his wife at
night a cop disguised as a prostitute is
seen following a woman to a man named
Leo the woman is introduced as Clary
Lynn the scene changes back to the
prison where the prison guard is paid
Frank gets ganged up by his cellmate he
beats all three of them and steals the
prison guard's clothes Frank tricks the
guards into opening the gates and he
escapes the police are informed by his
escape and Clary is assigned to the case
the scene shifts to a supermarket where
morel is seen taking an interest in a
girl named Melissa he tries to lure her
but fails as her mom calls her while
leaving he he finds out that Frank had
escaped prison and was wanted he moves
to his car where his wife was waiting
for him it seemed like they had Frank's
daughter along with him while looking
for possible Clues clary's team devises
a plan and sets out to a location of an
old apartment at the same time Adrian
enters the apartment in search of his
wife he doesn't find her but the police
arrive they entered the apartment but
don't find Frank they know that he had
been to the apartment due to the blood
splatters in the sink Clary figures
Frank's position and Corners him but he
escapes through the window the team
chases Frank down a highway where after
a long run he escapes by jumping on a
train something seemed to be driving
Frank's escape and Clary wanted to find
out the scene changes to where Frank is
seen taking a bus into a graveyard he
finds a stash of money gone but he also
finds his wife dead inside he called
Morel to question him Morel justifies
the reasoning for killing his wife as
the call ends Morel is seen in an
abandoned shed opening the medicine box
Clary and her team put out information
and try to rule Frank's next position
they locate the abandoned shed and
Frank's DNA is found on the stuff Morel
had planted the night before police
arrived the next morning and find a dead
body around the shed the person seemed
to be a girl named Julia who had
disappeared two years ago Clary still
suspicious finds it on for Frank to be a
killer and tries to investigate Frank
pays Morel a visit to find more clues
Morel believing him intends to help him
out and informs Frank about all morel's
previous victims to help him locate
morale Manuel goes to the police station
but while he's at it the truck driver
that had brought Frank to Manuel had
informed them about his whereabouts
acting fast the police in Luzon are
informed and they Corner Frank again but
he manages to escape with the gunshot
wound Manuel helps him escape and hands
in morel's location Frank jumps out of
his car and Manuel crashes his car into
the highway clary's team arrives at the
crash scene but Luciani decided to take
the case out of clary's hands Frank is
seen running across a field and steals a
car he arrives at the place Manuel told
them about locating the pharmacy he
finds a place closer to stay for a
lookout he treats his gunshot wound in
An Empty Apartment meanwhile Clary tries
to find more information about Frank's
history Morel and his wife are seen
walking in a marketplace where they spot
Melissa the girl from the supermarket
Burrell convinces his wife to abduct the
girl they ask her to show them the way
to the doctors when Christine tries to
cover her mouth sensing the danger
Melissa runs out of the car with Morel
chasing after her her run is cut short
with Morel grabbing and killing the girl
meanwhile Clary finds no solid evidence
of Frank being the killer she finds out
that Manuel is obsessed with finding
dirt against Morel the scene cuts to
Frank where he's seen looking out his
window he spots Morel and makes a run
for it he chases the car and ends up in
a mansion in the mountains Frank after
so long sees his daughter and decides to
take her away suspicious of morale Clary
makes her way to chastains to confront
him at night Frank makes it up to the
balcony to Emily's room picking her up
he tries to make it out of the house as
quietly as possible the doorbell rings
and Morel is seen chatting with Clary
the couple tries to convince her about
not having seen Frank and they assure
her to call her as soon as he makes
contact with them although he answers
her questions clearly it doesn't sit
right with Clary as soon as she leaves
Morel and his wife catch Frank escaping
with his daughter Christine takes Emily
back while Morel threatens to shoot him
Clary comes back and shoots at Morel
barely touching his ear taking advantage
Frank knocks him out and runs with Emily
out the door meanwhile the chief is
informed about clary's Mission and plans
to make it to morale's house promising
to take care of Clary Morel rushes after
the two Clary knocks Christine down and
makes her way to the two men Morel
catches up to the two and shoots up
Frank who is standing above a cliff
Frank hangs onto a tree right below the
cliff and as Morel is about to shoot him
Luciani stops him not being able to fool
them Clary shoots morale and he falls
off a cliff thinking that Frank was
julius's killer her father Robert at
Frank Annie falls down the cliff as well
three months after the incident Clary is
seen walking into a facility where Emily
now lives and the coordinator shows her
the letter that Emily had received and
that's where the movie ends click on one
of the two videos on screen right now